Hey! Welcome to AERA English TV.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
On top of a building on a very beautiful day.
So, today's Maestro Hook is about this. Ham.
But not the food, ham.
In the Western culture, whenever boys are talking or girls are talking,...
...there's always the ham.
It's one person who gets picked on or you make jokes about the person,...
...then that person is a ham.
It's kinda like the person that gets picked on,...
...but it's all fun and games so don't worry about it.
And also in English, we have the punch line.
And we have a punch line at the end of the story that makes the story funnier.
So sometimes, when someone's talking and there's no punch line,...
..."Hey, where did the punch line go?"
So, it's kinda like that.
Alright.
Do the math.
Come on, do the math.
Alright.
Duh!
What day is today?
Duh! Today is Wednesday.
Was today Wednesday?
Oh, come on! Do the math. It's Wednesday.
Native Lines. For example,...
..."Um, when was the meeting that was gonna be held today?"
"Come on, today. Do the math."
"Um, is today Wednesday? It was Tuesday yesterday."
"Yeah, duh! It's Wednesday."
So Native Maestro, next week keep tuned.
Alright, see you later!